يقوم الطيارون المغاربة بمسح المناظر الطبيعية أدناه بحثًا عن
الناجين من الزلزال، وقد تم
سحق بقايا القرى مرة أخرى في سفوح
التلال، ولا يمكن الوصول إليها عن طريق البر، وبعضها
بعيد جدًا لدرجة أن المساعدات تسقط من السماء
أسفل البحث عن الناجين
يتحول إلى انتشال الموتى، لذلك منذ
اليوم  عندما وصلنا إلى هنا، وجدنا
أكثر من 200 جثة
وأنقذنا 100. 53
المروحية تجمع المزيد من
ضحايا الزلزال تاركة المنازل التي لم
تعد موجودة،
وهناك العديد من المناطق التي لا تزال بحاجة إلى رؤية
مساعدة الحكومة في هذه التلال
كلما تقدمت  في سفوح
جبال الأطلس سواء عن طريق الجو أو
سيرًا على الأقدام، تخبرنا المزيد من المشاهد الجميلة مثل هذا
السكان المحليين أن شخصين
قُتلا عندما سويت هذه المنازل الثلاثة بالأرض،
وقد ارتفع عدد القتلى إلى أكثر من
2900 الآن باعتبارهم الأكثر فقرًا  يتم
إحصاء المعزولات، وعندما
يدخل المرء إلى هذه القرى النائية
وتنظر إلى
أسفل التل،
تحصل على انطباع قوي حقًا عن
الخطوات العملاقة لهذا الزلزال التي
تضرب القرى أثناء جريانها أسفل المنحدرات متسلقة
أكثر، حيث نواجه
بحثًا يائسًا عن  مدخرات مدفونة
كل ما تبقى عندما انهار منزل أحمد،
قتلت الكارثة
ابنة أخته أكيما البالغة من العمر عشر سنوات، أخبرني أنني
فقدت ابنة أخي يعيش أخي في
المنزل الذي فوقنا مباشرة عندما
ضرب الزلزال سطح المنزل وسوى بالأرض
على طول الطريق إلى  الأرض التي ذهبت إليها
وأخرجتها من تحت الأنقاض ما هو
المستقبل بالنسبة لك
أريد إعادة بناء منزلي ولكن
كل شيء قد ضاع أريد البقاء
في قريتي لا أريد أن أتركها
أنا ملتزم بالبقاء فيها  أرضي
ولكن مع موت ماشيته وحياة أحمد
تحطمت، لذا فإن السؤال الذي لا يستطيع
الإجابة عليه هو كيف
سام كايلي سي إن إن في تافر